Je vous suggère de faire attention à la raison pour laquelle je
dois dire que c'est un film d'action, mais il
a un thème intelligent fort sur le
terrorisme depuis trop longtemps vous avez
ignoré ce qui se passe autour de vous
vous n'avez pas vu l'inévitable qui
arrive la peau propre est  un film sur le
personnage de Sean Beans qui est un agent des
services secrets ex-forces spéciales ex-armée
qui chasse un kamikaze la plus méchante
cellule terroriste il vit une vie assez solitaire
nous avons dit que son oh et sa femme ont
été assassinés dans une situation de bombardier  dans
la situation de bombardier de Tony et ce genre d'
ajoute un peu de vengeance personnelle à son
personnage,
je veux que vous trouviez qui est responsable et que vous l'
arrêtiez de quelque manière que ce soit, vous savez que
je tuerais tous ceux que vous mettez devant moi
ouais je veux dire tout le monde dans le  le film est
imparfait, vous savez, les personnages de Sean Beans
imparfaits, les divagations superficielles imparfaites, je suis
imparfait, mais oui, je veux dire qu'il a une
humanité pour lui et c'est ce qui m'a attiré
vers le fait qu'il n'était pas une découpe en carton,
vous savez méchant pantomime méchant vous
trouvez o  mais pourquoi ils pensent que J explique
pourquoi ils font des choses, il ne justifie pas
pourquoi ils les font mais il y a beaucoup plus de
temps sur vous savez comment un haricot est progressivement
recruté et préparé pour être un jeune
terroriste un garçon peu sûr de vous,
citoyen britannique né  et élevé vous savez
et euh d'où le mot peau propre il n'y a
pas de casier judiciaire ou aucune
indication criminelle qu'il pourrait travailler pour
vous connaissez le problème de l'organisateur de stéréotypes
donc c'est un candidat parfait et
peu sûr comme dans intelligent mais vous
savez que ça tombe ça tombe  entre de mauvaises
mains ils ne sont pas Musto non plus
Je vais trouver chacun d'entre eux J'ai
commencé quand j'avais environ 20 ans tu sais 19
20 et je tu sais que je n'avais pas vraiment
envie de jouer avant ça
vous savez et je voulais dessiner et peindre
un peu comme dessiner de la peinture et j'en ai fait
pas mal à l'école j'étais très
très bon vous savez et il a gagné des
prix comme ce British Book of
birds c'était un guide dit britannique le
Livre britannique des oiseaux t  c'était à propos du
prix quand j'étais à l'école comme la
quatrième année quelque chose comme ça je suis
allé et je suis allé dans quelques écoles
et je n'ai jamais vraiment pu le
contourner alors j'ai juste rejoint l'
école de théâtre tu sais c'était gentil  en
parallèle avec ça et j'ai pensé qu'est-ce que le
dualisme pouvait changer quelque chose et je
n'étais pas très bon à quoi que ce soit vraiment
j'allais bien mais avec les actes je me sentais juste
vraiment à l'
aise  J'ai essayé de faire mon chemin
dans l'industrie et je ne
m'attirais vraiment pas parce que beaucoup de discussions
ont été faites et tout l'amour a été fait
et j'ai donc décidé de collecter des fonds moi-même, j'ai
trouvé un moyen de le faire et j'ai persévéré,
ce qui est très  important si vous êtes un
jeune cinéaste, je ne pense pas que vous
ayez une chance si vous ne persévérez pas
et que vous devez être passionnément obsédé
par votre cinéma, vous l'avez doit
être une chose de jour et de nuit à éviter
monter avant l'orkest et juste juste
croyez en vous-même rien d'autre n'augmente
la confiance en soi vient de la détermination de la confiance
vous savez que vous avez des coups
et des choses comme ça, mais vous le faites, mais
vous obtenez beaucoup de tresses aussi soyez une bonne
pause si vous croyez en ce que vous
faites et vous avez  le talent que vous avez
la passion l'engagement et ensuite vous pouvez le
faire vous savez que
cela nécessite un vous savez nécessite
beaucoup de passion beaucoup d'entre vous
doivent avoir une peau très épaisse toujours
rejetée pour des choses que vous voulez
monter  car et vous savez que vous n'êtes pas bon pour
mais en ce qui concerne les inspirations fluides ou les
influences, je pense que
c'est comme regarder des gens que vous connaissez et
à la télévision vous savez des films quand j'étais
plus jeune, j'étais en quelque sorte en train de m'inscrire ou de
tout prendre  mais je ne savais pas
nécessairement que cela
m'influencerait à devenir acteur et
avec le recul, c'était une sorte de
chose inconsciente des gens comme Albert
Finney et Peter O'Toole et le végétarien
John Hurt, il a été un grand héros derrière
th  à je travaille avec lui et je travaille avec tout
ça toutes ces affaires c'était juste mon boulot
c'est de faire ce qui est en ce moment pour t'embêter